J.R.R.
Tolkien: Father of Modern Fantasy
By: Crystal Sullivan
Known as ‘the father of modern fantasy’
his epic tales of legend and lore have been
enjoyed by millions of people all over the
world — devoured in popular books and adapted
for Hollywood blockbuster films.
Unbelievably bright, he was a distinguished
university professor, poet, historian, and
expert linguist.
As a child, he even made up his own languages
for pure fun.
He gave us complex and fanciful creatures
including hobbits, orcs, and elves set in
an prehistoric Middle-earth.
Some theorize his made up worlds are symbolic
of his country’s past power struggles, influenced
by his devout Roman Catholic faith, or simply
the genesis of his personal experiences.
In any case, there is no denying his glorious
imagination and his rightful place among the
greatest writers of all time.
But who was the creator of The Hobbit and
the Lord of the Rings?
Today on Biographics we explore the life of
J.R.R.
Tolkien.
Formative Years
Before bank clerk Arthur Tolkien and Mabel
Suffield welcomed their son into the world,
the English couple moved to South Africa.
Here, Arthur had high hopes of advancing his
career and providing a comfortable life for
their budding family.
John Ronald Reuel (known as “Ronald” to
most) was born in Bloemfontein, South Africa
on January 3, 1892.
Not long after, another son Hilary was born,
completing the Tolkien family.
Tolkien’s childhood in Africa was cut short
when his mother decided the boys would be
better educated in their native England.
At the age of three, Tolkien and his mother
and younger brother left for their homeland
while Arthur stayed behind to settle the business.
He was planning to join them but never made
it -- falling ill and dying of a severe brain
hemorrhage (a complication of rheumatic fever)
on February 15, 1896.
At the time, the spread of disease and contagions
were feared and travel took many weeks, if
not months.
Arthur’s body was laid to rest without family
by his side.
Having spent just a small fraction of his
early years in Africa, Tolkien had few memories
from the time.
However, one tale persists yet the facts remain
uncertain.
According to the story, the then-toddler Tolkien
stumbled upon and was bit by a baboon spider
(a kind of tarantula) in the garden.
Tolkien ran screaming and his nurse immediately
snatched him up and sucked the venom out from
the wound.
Tolkien later said, “...he could remember
a hot day and running in fear through long,
dead grass, but the memory of the tarantula
itself faded, and he said that the incident
left him with no especial dislike of spiders.”
Still, fans and armchair psychologists alike
speculate whether the tarantula influenced
the presence of man-eating spiders in Tolkien’s
later fictional works.
Back in England, Mabel and the boys settled
with family in the West Midlands — first
in Kings Heath and then in Sarehole.
On one hand, and especially in the city of
Birmingham, the West Midlands was urban, dark,
and industrial.
On the other hand, it was the idyllic English
countryside with
lush with green grass, trees, and a corn mill
in the rural hamlet of Sarehole.
Between the ages of four and eight, Tolkien
lived across the street and within 300 yards
of the Sarehole Mill and Moseley Bog.
He spent many hours playing there with his
younger brother — and being chased by the
miller’s son, whom the boys nicknamed the
“White Ogre.”
The Shire, Tolkien’s imaginary land of Hobbits,
was inspired by Sarehole.
In The Hobbit, he writes of Bilbo Baggins
"running as fast as his furry feet could carry
him down the lane, past the great Mill, across
The Water and then on for a mile or more."
Tolkien’s mother homeschooled the boys at
first, teaching the young Tolkien botany and
the basics of Latin.
Tolkien could read fluently by the age of
four and write soon after.
He loved drawing landscapes and trees but
his favorite studies were those involving
languages.
Later, he would attend King Edward’s School
in Birmingham which proved to be the perfect
breeding ground for the boy’s natural curiosity
and development of linguistics.
Tolkien was an exceptional student who was
capable of easily mastering ancient and modern
languages including Greek, Latin, Spanish,
Old English, Old Norse, Gothic and Finnish.
The boy made up his own languages, including
early variations of Elvish ones featured in
his writings.
At King Edwards, he made a number of close
friends and formed a semi-secret society that
enjoyed drinking tea and critiquing each other’s
literary works.
They called themselves T.C.B.S. (which stood
for the Tea Club and Barrovian Society).
Despite the earlier loss of his father, life
for the young Tolkien was generally happy
until two events altered the course of his
life.
In 1900, his mother decided to convert to
the Catholic faith.
This bold move left Mabel and her sons estranged
from both sides of the family and in the fallout,
Tolkien experienced isolation, loneliness,
and poverty.
Following his acceptance into the Catholic
church, Tolkien remained devout in his faith
for the rest of his life.
And, he has been credited with being partly
responsible for bringing another famous writer
and friend, C.S.
Lewis, back to Christianity.
Tragedy struck Tolkien again in 1904 when
his mother was diagnosed with diabetes — a
sure death sentence for most before insulin
was available.
Sadly, Mabel died in the same year, on November
14.
Tolkien was 12 at the time.
Fortunately for Tolkien and his brother Hilary,
their Catholic priest Father Francis Morgan
stepped in and became their guardian and made
sure the boys received everything they needed
— both materially and spiritually.
Lúthien and Beren
Tolkien met his eventual bride Edith Bratt
when he was 16, and she was 19.
They were both orphans and lodgers at a boarding
house run by a woman named Mrs. Faulkner.
The two grew fond of each other and a friendship
developed.
And then, as it happens with teenagers, the
pair became too close for Father Francis’
liking.
He was horrified his ward was courting a Protestant
woman and believed the relationship was a
distraction from Tolkien’s school work.
Father Francis forbade Tolkien to see or correspond
with Edith until he was 21.
This was a devastating blow to Tolkien but
he obeyed the order.
When his birthday approached, he wrote to
his love and proposed marriage.
Her reply was heartbreaking but offered a
glimmer of hope, she was engaged to another
man but his letter made her reconsider.
Edith agreed to meet Tolkien on January 8,
1913 at the train station in Cheltenham.
They walked and talked for hours and Edith
accepted Tolkien’s marriage proposal — breaking
off her prior engagement.
Edith converted to Catholicism and the couple
married on March 22, 1916.
Tolkien was 24 years old, and a few months
shy of deploying to the Western Front.
In a letter to his son Michael years later,
“Tolkien expressed admiration for his wife's
willingness to marry a man with no job, little
money, and no prospects except the likelihood
of being killed in the Great War.”
Tolkien was a true romantic and Edith was
his muse.
He wrote of her, “...her hair was raven,
her skin clear, her eyes brighter than you
have seen them, and she could sing — and
dance.”
Tolkien was so mad for Edith he created the
fictional pair of star-crossed lovers based
on their romance: Lúthien, daughter of the
Elven King of Doriath, and Beren, a mortal
man.
They fall for each other when Beren discovers
Lúthien singing and dancing in a glade.
Yet, their love can never be since Beren is
destined to die.
Alas, her disapproving father the King sends
Beren on a task he knows the man cannot complete.
The full story of Lúthien and Beren was left
unfinished during Tolkien’s lifetime but
served as an important backstory in The Hobbit.
Tolkien’s son Christopher later published
Lúthien and Beren as a chapter of the saga,
The Silmarillion.
Edith and Tolkien enjoyed a long and happy
marriage to each other and they had four children:
John Francis, Michael Hilary, Christopher
John, and Priscilla Mary Anne.
Tolkien was a devoted father and loved his
children, often making up fanciful stories
for them.
From 1920 to 1942 at Christmas time, Tolkien
illustrated letters to his children...introducing
new characters such as the North Polar Bear,
Snow Man and others, each year.
Three years after his death, these intimate
stories were published as Letters from Father
Christmas by the Tolkien estate.
The Great War
Believing he was in his own words, "a young
man with too much imagination and little physical
courage," Tolkien did not rush to join the
British military when war broke out.
Instead, he returned to Oxford where he had
achieved a first-class degree in June of 1915.
Tolkien was busy working on poems and his
invented languages at the time.
Eventually though, Tolkien enlisted as a second
lieutenant in the Lancashire Fusiliers and
was sent to active duty on the Western Front
just in time for the Battle of the Somme (also
known as the Somme Offensive).
The Battle of the Somme remains one of the
bloodiest military battles in history.
It lasted four long months and on the first
day alone, British troops suffered over 57,000
casualties.
In total, over a million men lost their lives
including 420,000 British soldiers.
Fighting in the Great War, Tolkien witnesses
the horrors of trench fighting and lived in
deplorable, unsanitary conditions.
It was hell on earth for Tolkien and his comrades
who stood by as their friends suffered and
died alongside them.
They spent their days and nights with little
relief and endured infestations of lice that
feasted on their flesh.
As a result, Tolkien came down with “trench
fever,” a major medical problem of World
War I.
So severe was the lice, a chaplain staying
with Tolkien’s unit later recalled:
“... We dossed down for the night in the
hopes of getting some sleep, but it was not
to be.
We no sooner lay down than hordes of lice
got up.
So we went round to the Medical Officer, who
was also in the dugout with his equipment,
and he gave us some ointment which he assured
us would keep the little brutes away.
We anointed ourselves all over with the stuff
and again lay down in great hopes, but it
was not to be, because instead of discouraging
them it seemed to act like a kind of hors
d'oeuvre and the little beggars went at their
feast with renewed vigour.
Sick and unable to fight, Tolkien left the
battlefront to recover in a Birmingham hospital
in November of 1916.
Through 1917 and 1918 Tolkien had recurring
bouts of the illness and he spent the time
in remission doing service at home and at
various camps.
Tolkien most likely escaped death on the battlefront
precisely because he became ill.
Sadly, all but one of his close friends, including
those from the T.C.B.S., perished in the war.
As a writer, this tragedy of loss and first-hand
experience in battle provided Tolkien with
a keen sense of awareness.
From the unpublished, The Book of Lost Tales,
Tolkien writes, “… in huts full of blasphemy
and smut, or by candle light in bell-tents,
even some down in dugouts under shell fire.”
In The Hobbit, The Battle of the Five Armies
is thought to draw upon Tolkien’s wartime
experiences, as well as the Dead Marshes and
Black Gate of Mordor in The Lord of the Rings.
On November 11, 1918, the Armistice was signed
marking the end of World War I.
The Professor
Tolkien was appointed Assistant Lexicographer
on the New English Dictionary (the “Oxford
English Dictionary”) in 1918 but stayed
on the job for only a short while.
In the summer of 1920, he accepted a post
as a Reader with the University of Leeds.
At Leeds, he taught and collaborated with
other authors, continued writing The Book
of Lost Tales, constructed languages, and
founded reading and social clubs like the
“Viking Club,” where undergraduates had
an affinity for Old Norse sagas and drinking
beer.
In 1925, Tolkien finally received his professorship
at Oxford, the Rawlinson and Bosworth Professorship
of Anglo-Saxon.
Tolkien was right at home in academia and
fit in remarkably well with the predominantly
male culture.
He reveled in the lectures, research, and
exchange of ideas with students and fellow
professors.
Tolkien did not publish many scholarly articles
yet he was extremely influential.
One lecture worth mentioning altered the modern
study of the Old English epic tale Beowulf
and was first delivered in 1936.
In “Beowulf, the Monsters and the Critics,”
Tolkien argued the monsters: Grendel, Grendel’s
mother, and the Dragon, are not merely extraneous
to the narrative but should be a focus of
study.
Tolkien believed critics put too much emphasis
on the historical elements of the tale instead
of looking at it as a work of art.
At Oxford, Tolkien befriended colleague C.S.
Lewis, best known for his fantasy series,
The Chronicles of Narnia.
The two men bonded over their shared love
of mythology and began meeting regularly for
a glass, a joke, and to criticize each other’s
poetry.
The meetings were so enjoyable and useful,
they invited others to join.
The informal group, known as “The Inklings”
eventually grew to 19 members and they met
once a week, late at night, sometimes not
wrapping up until two or three o’clock in
the morning.
As was the practice, Tolkien shared manuscripts
of works-in-progress with The Inklings and
received energetic feedback from the group.
Among other writings, Tolkien brought original
poetry, sections from The Hobbit, excerpts
from “The Notion Club Papers,” and each
new chapter of The Lord of the Rings.
There is little evidence to support the suggestion
by some that the men had a more spiritual
purpose to their meetings, or an “inkling”
of the Divine Nature.
The Inklings continued to meet regularly for
19 years.
Together with Tolkien and Lewis, some of the
more distinguished members of The Inklings
included Neville Coghill, Hugo Dyson, Owen
Barfield, and Charles Williams.
In 1945 Tolkien changed his chair at Oxford
to the Merton Professorship of English Language
and Literature, which he held until his retirement
in 1959.
The Storyteller
One hot summer day in 1928, Professor Tolkien
was grading exam papers, which he described
as “soul-destroying.”
He came upon a blank page — and without
thought —wrote down, “In a hole in the
ground there lived a hobbit.”
But, What was a hobbit?
And, Why did it live in the ground?
Tolkien needed to find the answers to these
questions.
He said later, “Names always generate a
story in my mind.
I thought I’d better find out what hobbits
were like.”
Then, in true Tolkien fashion, he dove headlong
into the creative process and concocted a
tale to tell his younger children, and share
amongst The Inklings.
In 1936, an incomplete copy of The Hobbit
wound up in Susan Dagnall’s hands, an employee
of the publishing firm of George Allen and
Unwin.
Recognizing the story’s potential, Dagnall
convinced Tolkien to finish it and when complete,
she presented it to her boss.
He then tested it out on his 10-year old son
who gave it a raving review.
The Hobbit was published one year later in
1937, and was an immediate hit.
In fact, it was so successful, the publisher
asked Tolkien if he had any similar stories.
Today, since the first publication, The Hobbit
has sold over 100 million copies around the
world and has been translated in over 50 languages.
What makes The Hobbit so enduring?
For one thing, it lacks female characters
and it is not, nor ever has been, politically
correct.
It is also a very long tale with poetry, and
unlike other children’s fiction, does not
have a central child figure for whom young
readers can easily identify with.
Although, the protagonist Bilbo Baggins is
“only a little hobbit,” so he kind of
acts like a surrogate child.
Tolkien’s colorful descriptions of Middle-earth
and its complex characters (goblins, elves,
orcs, wizards, dragons, and hobbits of course)
are richly portrayed.
And for all the fantasy writers who came after
Tolkien, hardly any can say their worlds were
not, at least in part, influenced by The Hobbit.
But, what set the story apart is the depth
of emotion and moral courage Tolkien weaves
into his heroic fiction.
There are examples of this throughout The
Hobbit including the death of dwarf leader
Thorin Oakenshield, and Bilbo’s internal
struggles to do what is right — betraying
his friends while they try to reclaim the
Lonely Mountain from Smaug the dragon.
Bilbo feels an obsessive greed has overtaken
Thorin and when Bilbo finds the Arkenstone,
the greatest treasure of all, he decides to
first hide it and then give it to his friends’
besiegers to be used as a bargaining chip.
In the end Bilbo exposes himself and confesses
because after all, they are friends.
After Tolkien’s publication of The Hobbit,
he presented portions of The Silmarillion,
including incomplete stories of Lúthien and
Beren, to Stanley Unwin hoping for a warm
reception but his reader felt the stories
were not commercially publishable.
They contained too much poetry.
Tolkien was disappointed at the news but soon
found himself busy writing the sequel to The
Hobbit.
Tolkien’s opus, what would become The Lord
of the Rings, was first published in three
parts: The Fellowship of the Ring, The Two
Towers, and The Return of the King between
1954 and 1955.
And, it took him over a decade to write it.
Unwin’s son, who was by now an adult, was
heavily involved in pushing a tempermental
Tolkien along to finish it.
Thinking it would be a relative unimpressive
release, and a loss to the firm, the publishers
grossly underestimated The Lord of the Rings
public appeal.
True, it had mixed reviews — from damning
to glowing and everything in between.
BBC adapted it into 12 condensed episodes,
elevating its popularity further.
Then, in the mid-1960s a pirated paperback
version was released which caught the attention
of American readers.
A sort of cult developed based on the newfound
popularity of fantasy literature and Tolkien
was made a rich man.
He was not entirely happy though, even if
he was flattered.
Partly, because rumors circulated of party-going
cult readers ingesting LSD and reading The
Lords of the Rings.
And some overzealous fans, who Tolkien referred
to as lunatics, were calling his home demanding
to know if Frodo had succeeded in his quest.
The Hobbit and The Lord of the Rings certainly
receive all the glory but Tolkien authored
a number of other articles and essays during
his lifetime including: The Monsters and the
Critics and Other Essays; one Middle-earth
related work, The Adventures of Tom Bombadil;
editions and translations of Middle English
works such as the Ancrene Wisse, Sir Gawain,
Sir Orfeo and The Pearl, and stories the Imram,
The Homecoming of Beorhtnoth Beorhthelm’s
Son, The Lay of Aotrou and Itroun, Farmer
Giles of Ham, Leaf by Niggle, and Smith of
Wootton Major.
Following his death, The Letters from Father
Christmas were released by the Tolkien estate,
and later, son Christopher saw to it that
his father’s Silmarillion and a number of
other incomplete writings under the title
of Unfinished Tales of Númenor and Middle-earth
were published.
After his retirement from Oxford Tolkien moved
to Bournemouth and on November 29, 1971 the
love of his life, Edith died.
Nearly two years later on September 2, 1973
Tolkien followed.
As a final testament to their love, and at
Tolkien’s instruction, they were buried
in a single grave.
On their tombstone, "Beren" is engraved under
his name and "Luthien" appears under Edith’s.
Accomplishments & Legacy
Tolkien shall remain a celebrated literary
figure through the ages as his life work continues
to inspire the fantasy genre.
Around the world, his characters and places
have become the namesake of various street
names, companies, mountains, plants, and objects.
There are even asteroids named after Bilbo
Baggins and Tolkien himself.
In England, there are seven blue plaques that
commemorate places associated with Tolkien.
Tolkien was made a Commander of the Order
of the British Empire by Queen Elizabeth II
in 1972.
And, he holds a number of other achievements
and awards including: an honorary degree from
The National University of Ireland and University
of Liege in 1954, and the Locus Award for
Best Fantasy novel for The Silmarillion in
1978.
In the 2000s, Tolkien ranked on BBC’s ‘greatest
Britons’ list and The Lord of the Rings
was the UK’s ‘best loved novel’ (2003)
and ranked among ‘The 100 Greatest British
Novels’ (2015).
Tolkien was placed sixth on the list of ‘The
50 greatest British writers since 1945’
published by ‘The Times’ in 2008.
In 2009, he was listed as the fifth top-earning
‘dead celebrity’ by Forbes.
From 2001 to 2003, New Line Cinema released
The Lord of the Rings as a trilogy directed
by Peter Jackson.
The series was extremely successful and won
numerous Oscars.
From 2012 to 2014, Warner Bros. and New Line
Cinema released The Hobbit, a series of three
films based on The Hobbit.
The first in 2012, The Hobbit: An Unexpected
Journey, the second in 2013, The Hobbit: The
Desolation of Smaug, and the final instalment
in 2014, The Hobbit: The Battle of the Five
Armies.
Most recently, Amazon retained the rights
to adapt The Lord of the Rings for its Prime
streaming service.
The multi-season adaptation, will focus on
“previously unexplored stories based on
J.R.R.
Tolkien’s original writings,” according
to a representative for the Tolkien Estate.
Tolkien’s Middle-earth is surely the gift
that keeps on giving.
And It is quite amazing, considering he wrote
it all in his spare time.